the rebellion is spreading I want to be
on the side I believe in ya meanwhile
I'm stuck here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my own meow
pushy
you know the rebellion against the
Empire that's how he came to be in your
service if you take my meaning sir
fathers liked saver
this is livin of a Jedi Knight
before the dark times before the Empire
they grow tired of asking this is going
to be the last time
where is the rebel base there's nothing
for me here now I want to learn the ways
of the force and become a Jedi like my
father
I've placed information remember
sar to you
you must see this droid safely delivered
to him on
captain Lee won applause
Chewie here tells me you're looking for
passage to the Alderaan system
you must learn the ways of the force if
you wanna come with me to Alderaan
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to rescue
the great disturbance in the force
the battle station is heavily shielded
there is a firepower greater than half
the Starfleet
don't underestimate
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]